hello and welcome to the abbott
hematology hit series today on the art
and science of hematology morphology
rbc
morphology i am marie stone of labrutz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
today our presenter daniel pelling will
share more of his decades-long
experience in morphology concentrating
on red blood cells dan is the site
manager for blood sciences at st mary's
hospital paddington which is part of
northwest london pathology based in the
uk
he has extensive training in the
laboratory and has multiple degrees and
holds the highest specialist diploma in
hematology and is qualified in forensic
medicine
in his spare time he leads educational
efforts in the hematology community
he teaches at both undergraduate and
postgraduate level is the lead tutor for
the english program stream of the
multilingual international education
program
ehemat image
and holds advisory positions in uk
nequos institute for biomedical sciences
and the european hematology association
here are today's learning objectives
dan will observe a smear from normal
blood showing the degrees of natural
variation in red cell size and shape and
the importance of staining relative to
rbcs
he will also review smears that show
abnormal rbc morphology talking us
through selected case studies including
microacydic and macrocytic anemias
dan will also discuss red cell fragments
as an abnormal finding and the
importance of differentiating these from
platelets here are the required
disclosures and disclaimers for today's
presentation
it is now my pleasure to welcome dan
dan you may begin your presentation
thank you very much for the introduction
there and i would just like to reiterate
uh
the thanks for blood academy for being
allowed to use their resources
the ability to look at the slide in real
time and to be able to move around the
slide is very important for
for people to get
the bigger picture the idea of what the
whole slide looks like
i will be looking at a number of cases
of reticle morphology for the next half
hour or so and they'll be moving between
different screens
and the screens will be changing from
small images to large images as we move
around the slides
this will give a far greater overall
impression of some of the changes that
we're going to see
for this red blood cell presentation
so there we have it the humble red blood
cell
a small six to eight micrometer in
diameter cell
that's a bi-concave disc
which essentially means it's shaped like
a donut except the hole doesn't go all
the way through in the middle
it's surrounded by its lipid bilayer and
supported by a number of structural
proteins that are trans membrane
sit within the membrane
and that support the membrane on the
cytosolic side of the red cell
the red cell is usually round
and we use the term disco site to
describe that morphologically
but because of the nature and the makeup
of the red cells lipid bilayer and
because of changes in those structural
proteins that sit around the membrane
it can often take on different shapes
and sometimes taking on those different
shapes is a reversible change sometimes
it's permanent and we're going to look
at some cases where we can identify
these differences in shape
and talk about some of the causes
one term that we need to be clear on
before we start
is the word poechilocytosis
poikilocytosis is a general term
that means difference in shape
we often see it written down on the
hematology reports
blood film shows poi kilo sites
to be honest that's not always a very
useful term when it's used in its own
right
it is far more useful to describe what
type of poinkilla site you're seeing on
the blood film
is it an ellipticite
is it a sickle cell
is it a spherocyte
or is it some other bizarre shape that
looks like a fish or a mushroom
and yes we do get cells that are shaped
like fish and mushrooms sometimes
but without knowing what normal looks
like to start with how can we really
gauge what's abnormal
and that's where we're going to start
now what is the normal morphological
appearance of the red cell
i'm going to share my screen and we're
going to move in and out of this slide
here
i hope that everyone who is registered
for this webinar can see a full screen
picture now of lots of red cells
if i scroll
in
then we can see the images
enlarging and we can see that we're
looking at a part of the blood film
where the red cells are
just touching or maybe ever so slightly
overlapping in some areas
this is the ideal place on the blood
film to assess red cell morphology
because we can see the individual cells
not only can we see the actual cell
outlines individually but we can also
see these pale scent areas of central
palette
the area of central palette in a normal
red cell
should be approximately one third the
diameter of the overall red cell
diameter
and we know that we are in the correct
part of the film when we can see the
central pallet in the vast majority of
cells
if we're looking at a part of the blood
film that is too thin
the central palate is lost and the red
cells appear
slightly
macrocytic
if we're looking at a part of the blood
film that is too thick we can't find the
monolayer we can't see the cells
individually and we can't therefore
assess
the differences in size and shape
so here we are looking at an ideal part
of the blood film we can see the red
cells with their central palla and their
general round shape
yes we do have some slight variations in
shape the occasional slightly smaller
cell the occasional slightly larger cell
but the occasional cell that's got a
little project a projection coming from
it
but
overall the majority of the cells look
nice and round and normal that's
enormous
picture
but how can we tell what size these red
cells are
we have our mcv calculations and results
from our full blood count analyzers but
how do we know that's accurate
well as a rough rule of thumb
the normal red cell
should be roughly the same size as the
nucleus of a normal small lymphocyte
that is a rough rule of thumb and it
helps us assess
red cell morphology
even in the normal healthy subject there
will be the occasional smaller cell the
occasional larger cell the occasional
misshapen cell and sometimes
as the differences and shapes are due to
smearing artefacts
and what we will also occasionally note
is that sometimes there will be the red
cell that has a slight blue gray tinge
to it
we call that the polychromatic red cell
and it's equivalent to a late stage
reticular site because there are some
red cells that are circulating out there
that have yet to fully mature and within
a matter of a few hours to maybe a day
that will become a fully mature red cell
and lose this blue gray tinge
what is very important when you're
looking at the blood film of a patient
with an unexpected or unexplained anemia
it is
to note the degree of polychromasia one
would expect to see increased
polychromasia increased blue-gray tinge
to the red cells when the hemoglobin is
lower
because that indicates the marrow is
responding to the anemia by pushing out
red cells slightly ahead of time so it
can compensate
so
it's not a very exciting feature but
it's a very important feature to note
and this
is our normal
red cells
what you will find occasionally is
sometimes when you zoom in or look at a
blood film under too higher
magnification
those subtle differences in shape can
feel more prominent and that can lead to
over reporting
differences
in cell size and in cell shape
and of course over reporting can be
sometimes as misleading as under
reporting or missing a feature
and to avoid that it's often more useful
to look at the blood film at a slightly
lower magnification to start with so you
can get an a much wider overall appear a
feeling for the red cells
and the white cell count and also the
platelet count as well
platelets we will be talking about in a
future webinar
as i move through the various tabs that
i've got open from the blood academy
website
we will notice
the difference
in the red cell appearance as we talk
about different
conditions
and the next condition i'm going to look
at
is
this
a severe iron deficiency
now i've chosen to look at a severe iron
deficiency here because it really
emphasizes
the distinction between the cell shape
and size
so we know that our humble red cell as i
said it's circulating around it's packed
with hemoglobin giving it that pink
color
performing that very important process
gaseous exchange
and normally it's six to eight
micrometers in diameter
well here we see a lot of red cells that
do not look normal they certainly don't
look like the cells on our previous
slight bed
it
this whole slide looks far more pale
the red cells look almost as if they're
just a small ring
of hemoglobin around the edge the area
of central palate in the vast majority
of your cells is far bigger than just a
third the diameter of the
of the rest of the cell
when we see these cells there are a
number of other terms that we can begin
to use
so the cells
that look like just a thin
rim of hemoglobin around the edge
they are known as hypochromic cells hypo
being less chromic being colored so they
have less color they are hyperchromic
cells
and if we were to compare the red cells
from our previous slide to the red cells
on this
slide we would see that a lot of the
cells on this slide are much smaller i
would probably say somewhere between
four and five microns or maybe five to
six microns in diameter
so not only are they more pale
because they have less hemoglobin
they're hyperchromic
they're smaller they're microacidic
so we have what's called here an overall
hypochromic microcytic
acidic hyperchromic picture
and the most common disorder across the
globe that gives rise to this picture is
iron deficiency anemia
with insufficient iron uptake and
insufficient
and or i suppose insufficient iron usage
from your diet
to make sufficient hemoglobin
there are many many causes of a
microcytic hypochromic picture
we are going to be looking at one
another one slightly later on but as i
say the most common is iron deficiency
anemia
and it is important to confirm this when
you're looking at the blood film your
analyzer has given you a low mcv
and a low mch
and possibly in severe iron deficiency a
low nchc mean cell hemoglobin
concentration
so looking at the blood film and
providing a comment that either is
microcytosis confirmed or film
consistent with results is very
important
you are using a reporting style that
adds value to the results coming off the
analyzer
not only did we see microscopic
hyperchromic cells in in iron deficiency
we also see variations in cell shape as
well we can often see cells that are
slightly teardrop shaped which shows
they have a slight
point
just to one pole of the cell
that's not uncommon
we often see cells that are more oval or
elliptical
in iron deficiency
and when this oval an elliptical change
becomes even more extreme we see the
cell is almost as if it's being looks as
if it's been pulled out with parallel
sides
that is
quite specific
to eye deficiency
and that appearance of the cell
is called a pencil cell because it has
long straight parallel sides
so this variation in size and color and
shape is
very typical of iron deficiency as is
an increased platelet count it is not
uncommon as part of the reactive process
to see a mild to moderate
thrombocytosis increasing platelet
counts
in iron deficiency
let's move on to our next slide
it is quite good at showing these slides
next to each other the iron deficiency
followed by this particular condition
which is a beta thalassemia tray
thalassemia refers to the condition
where certain globin chains
aren't produced at the correct rates
beta thalassemia means that the
beta-globin gene of hemoglobin is being
produced at a reduced rate
and that means the cells will not
contain the same amount of hemoglobin as
a normal red cell
there's a chain imbalance
hemoglobin is made of alpha chains and
beta chains or sometimes alpha chains
and delta chains or alpha chains and
gamma chains
depending upon the type of hemoglobin
you're looking at
or talking about
beta thalassemia refers to a reduced
rate of beta-globin chain synthesis
and that also leads to a microcytic
hyperchromic picture
here we
can see
roughly in the middle of the screen a
relatively normal small lymphocyte
if we look at the size of the nucleus of
that small lymphocyte we can see just by
eyeballing the film
that the majority of red cells appear
smaller in diameter
so the majority of red cells are
microcytic
and we can see that uh there's quite a
high number of cells that look pale
again with this area central palette
bigger than expected in a normal patient
so they too are hypochromic
and we can also see mild variation in
cell shape as well
but the variation in cell shape is not
as marked or as prominent
or as varied
as ones sees in iron deficiency
so microcytic hyperchromic pictures can
also be seen
in thalassemia and not just beta
thalassemia as i'm showing here but also
alpha thalassemia
and to some degree in delta thalassemias
as well
the difference between the iron
deficient picture
and the thalassemic picture
is that the red cell population is is
much less varied so it is more
monomorphic it has more of a sort of one
one picture to it
that can be
confirmed by looking at other parameters
coming off the full blood count analyzer
such as the red cell distribution width
or what's known as the rdw
the red cell distribution width is to
all intents and purposes a measure of
change and variation in red cell size
the term we use to describe variation in
red cell size is anisocytosis
in iron deficiency anemia as we saw in
the previous slide
marked variation in red cell size
equals marked anisocytosis
which is shown by an increased value of
the rdw on the analyzer
a similar microcytic hypochromic picture
but with a relatively normal stable rdw
and little anisocytosis
is much more indicative of a thalassemic
picture
and we'll just move around the slide
and show how all the cells
look fairly similar
again in thalassemia it is not uncommon
to see an increased number of these
teardrop or slightly pointy
cells
we call them teardrop cells or say they
look a bit pointy but they too
have a proper name
and they're called
dacrocytes
what is also not uncommon to see in
thalassemia and we can see an example of
two features here
in the middle of the screen or i
certainly hope it's in the middle of
your screen as you're looking at it
is a cell that looks like it's got a
bull's eye in the middle
it in fact it looks a bit like a dart
board or maybe an archery target and
indeed it's called a target cell
target cells also have more scientific
names they're called codocytes
codo
science coder science
and we often see an increased number of
these target cells or codocytes
in thalassemia again it's another
feature that helps us distinguish
between the different types of
microcytosis and hyperchromic pictures
what we can also see on the particular
kodacite target cell that we're looking
at in the middle here
is a slight
stippled effect
basophilic stippling
isophilic stippling again is not
uncommon in the thalassemia yes you can
see it in many other conditions but
looking at the bigger picture here
trying to distinguish between iron
deficiency and thalassemia we can see
increased number of target cells and the
presence of basophilic
stippling the greater the reduction of
globin chain synthesis and the greater
the chain imbalance between alpha chains
and beta chains
the more marked these features become
our cells aren't always just small
sometimes cells are large as well not
larger than expected and in our next
slide
we're going through an example of
cells that have got an increased mean
cell volume
so
for the vast majority of laboratory
hematology laboratories globally normal
healthy adult male
and that's usually about 12 years
and fema adults usually about 12 years
and above will have a mean cell volume
that ranges between
about 83 84 femtometers up to about
98.99
femtoliters
local
ranges may change the disclaimer here is
always match your assessment of blood
films with your locally derived ranges
but generally anything above about 99
femtoliters and 99 100 up to the 100 the
low hundreds hundred and tens hundred
and twenties
macrocytic macro being large acidic
being cell macrocytic
and again if we see
a small lymphocyte try and find a small
lymphocyte normal small emphasize on our
film we can see that many of the red
cells here
are larger and some significantly so
than the nucleus of this small
lymphocyte remember it's not the small
lymphocyte itself it's the nucleus of
the small lymphocytes that we're
assessing against
what is quite common to know
about when we have macrocytic cells
is that many of them often lack their
central power even though we know we are
looking in the correct part of the film
but there are many things that can cause
macrocytosis
again one of one of the most common
conditions we see
um is
what's called megaloblastic anemia
where there is a deficiency of either
vitamin b12
or folic acid in the diet
however
liver dysfunction and liver pathologies
can also give rise to a macrocyclosis
and other less common conditions such as
myelodysplasia and bone marrow failure
syndromes can also give rise to
macrocytosis
but the macrocytosis in liver failure
for example is very frequently
associated with an increased number of
target cells
on the blood film
and we saw target cells on our previous
film so i use that term confidently now
knowing that you're probably looking at
this blood film thinking can i see any
of those bulls-eye target like cells
well
can't
really they don't
need to be very many at all
the occasional hint of one
but not very prominent
so this probably rules out liver disease
in this particular patient that we're
looking at now
well i know that to be true because this
particular patient that we're looking at
now
actually had a b12 vitamin b12
deficiency
and that was the cause of the
macrocytosis
vitamin 12 is a cofactor for production
of
of the purines eventually through the
biochemical python of the purines that
are incorporated into dna
and
without vitamin b12 that metabolic
process
can't proceed
so dna synthesis is
uh is slowed down
which means the red cell matures the
cytoplasm materials but the nucleus
doesn't and we get this condition of
cytoplasmic and nuclear asynchrony
giving rise to macrocytic red cells oh
there's a target cell just the one
one target cell doesn't make a diagnosis
so if you think you have macrocytosis
and they look like this consider the
number of target cells
consider what the other cell lineages
are doing are they reduced are they
increased are we looking at a
hematological abnormality
that's derived from the bone marrow
and it will help you draw your
conclusions and again provide statements
on your report that add value
again
in the condition of medulloblastic
anemia it is not uncommon
since the occasional teardrop cell the
dachrocytes
to see the occasional vasophilic
stippling
and to see the occasional red cell
fragments as well
now that is very important we're going
to look at fragments in a little bit of
depth in just a few minutes
i'm going to move on to my next slide
now
this is what the slide looks like under
very low magnification
i'll make my screen full and as we zoom
in
we begin to see that some of the cells
actually look like they're just bits of
cells bits of cells with sharp edges and
straight lines and
[Music]
they're not round
let's make sure we're looking in the
right part of the film where if there
are any around the cells we can see the
central panel
actually looks a little bit tricky here
but
let's look at some of these cells in a
bit more detail some of them look like
they've actually had a bit of a cheese
wire run across them and they're
fragmented with sharp edges and straight
lines
and that's not just because this is
actually a an image of stitched
stitched pictures together there are
some genuine fragmented red cells
we're going to zoom in here
we've got one red cell here that that
looks like it's been chopped off almost
halfway through and it's missing the
side of it and there are two little
horns sticking out there
that's got a specific name
it's called a helmet cell more
scientifically it's called keratocyte
and it is a red cell fragment
we have just a remnants of a red cell
here a red cell fragment
we have a very small
dark round cell here
that's got no central power
a spherocyte
a spherocyte is a type of red cell
fragments
when you see red cell fragments on the
blood film it is
incredibly important to immediately
assess
the number of platelets
increased red cell fragments associated
with a low platelet count
can indicate a number of
life-threatening conditions
that you as the hematology
scientist in the laboratory or the
morphologist looking at the film
have to prioritize
low platelet count and metal fragments
can be seen in conditions called vic
disseminated intravascular coagulation
it's also associated with coagulopathy
as an abnormal clotting screen results
red cell fragments and low platelets can
sometimes be seen
often be seen in fact in hemolytic
uremic syndrome
and other conditions that come under the
umbrella of
microangiopathic hemolytic anemias
or thrombotic microangiopathies
but what one condition that is very
important is a condition called ttp
thrombotic thrombocytopenic papura
associated with
usually a
moderate increase in the number of red
cell fragments
even in the normal healthy patient
you're going to see maybe
one fragment every
fifth or sixth field that you look at
but any more than that
you should be worried about an increase
in the number of retail fragments and
again as i say if associated with a
reduced platelet count
it could signal the patient has
developed ttp
ttp is life threatening and very quickly
so
whether you're working a day shift and
it's 11 o'clock in the morning or you're
working a night shift and it's three
o'clock in the morning
unless you have got a critical condition
in a blood transfusion setting that
you're dealing with
ttp is your priority
to report on and let the clinical teams
know
ttp is often associated with a
a low hemoglobin it can be variable
so we also need to assess the degree of
polychromasia
but as cells get even younger than just
a reticulocyte we find that we come
across the red cells that haven't yet
lost their nucleus it hasn't been
extruded and that's where we see the new
circulating nucleated red cells and
here's a perfect example here
this is a late nucleated red cell
with its very dark very round
nucleus
and
cytoplasm that has still got a great
hinge because of the uh the ribosomes
but it's beginning to change current a
little bit because it's getting more
hemoglobin
in some settings this might be referred
to as a
orthochromatic
red cell
or orthochromatic normoblast
or a late polychromatic normoblast
here's a nucleated red cell
nucleated red cells
on the blood film
outside of a couple of conditions
are always abnormal and they are the
ones so if you see one you must say so
occasionally very occasionally you may
see one or two circulating in the blood
of a completely normal healthy pregnant
female
within the first few days of birth of a
normal healthy term infants you might
see up to five nucleated red cells per
100 white cells circulating and
gradually over those first few days that
number will get less
reduce
if
the baby is pre-term or is born with
conditions sepsis or there was maybe a
slightly traumatic birth
you may see up to about maybe 20
nucleated red cells per 100 white cells
circulating over the first week a few
days
again that will decrease
outside of those conditions
they're abnormal they shouldn't be there
there's some
something going on you need to report on
them
here we have some more lovely jagged red
cell fragments
this actually was from a patient that
had ttp
we're going to move on to the last
couple of slides now
well if we're signed up for the
hematology lectures here the hematology
webinars
i
hope that i don't have to go through in
too much detail what we're looking at
here
we're looking at red cells that are very
bizarrely shaped very pointy very sharp
curved
in fact almost like the blade of a
sickle that one would use to cut the
grass
and yes what we have here
is an example of
lots of sickle cells
are from a sickle anemia patient
so instead of having hemoglobin a they
have hemoglobin s and they have a double
dose of it hemoglobin ss sickle anemia
the hemoglobin the beta s hemoglobin
polymerizes into long tubes and it
pushes out within the red cell membrane
and because the red cell membrane is
flexible it develops these pointy ends
sometimes
the cells in cyclinia aren't always
curved and pointy sometimes they're a
little bit more stubby
but the same process
is still responsible this
polymerization
of hemoglobin within the cell
we're going to move on to my final slide
here
so we've seen some examples of
poikilocites sickle cells maybe some
elliptocytes some acrocytes
and some spherocytes well here we can
see some very bizarrely shaped cells
they've got irregular large projections
sticking out from them
but certainly not normal at all some of
them look dark and that they've lost
their central power
they're hyperchromic
when we see these cells with a number of
irregular projections large irregular
but they're not
parts of projections that you would see
from red cell fragments or schistocytes
then
we call these cells acanthocytes
some cells we see they often have a very
regular number of small
spine-like projections
and about 12 or 15 more of small
irregular small irregular regularly
spaced spine like projections around the
surface of the red cell usually signals
what's called an eclinosite
they look like an echinoderm
that's why they're called eclinosites
but that must be distinguished between
these other cells that have much fewer
much less number of large
irregular projections
which are the acanthocites
it has different connotations it means
something different different mechanisms
of formation
so the acanthocytes are
usually due to an imbalance of lipids in
the red cell lipid bilayer
an imbalance in the amount of
cholesterol
it can also be due to mutations in the
structural proteins of the red cell
membrane
it can be seen they can be seen
in uh a cancer cytosis neuroaccount for
cytosis
a b to lipoproteinemia
uh decompression illness in scuba divers
that can sometimes be
seen
and they can also be seen
in mcleod syndrome which is associated
with the rhesus null very rare phenotype
so morphology can be linked to blood
transfusion there which is really rather
remarkable
whereas the cells with the smaller more
regular
spine like projections
the increased number
the echinocytes
are more often associated with pyruvate
kinase deficiency or renal insufficiency
but the big takeaway message from this
last slide is that sometimes we can see
any of these shapes
through artifact
one of the most common artifacts is
stored blood a film that's been made
from blood that is too old
so we must always make sure that when
we're assessing our red cells shape our
red cell size our red cell color that
we're doing it from a fresh film that
ideally is made from an edta sample
that is less than two to four hours old
i work in the real world i know that is
not always possible in a laboratory so
morphologists must be aware of that
and if you're aware of what's normal and
aware of artifacts that can come in and
influence what's normal
then
you should have a very long and
prosperous career
in assessing what's abnormal
and
certainly with morphology it is
fascinating
how things can be linked together
and
anyone who is beginning their journey i
wish you all the best and i hope that we
can deliver many more of these webinars
with abbott
um to help you on your journey
that is a whirlwind tour through some
red cell features there are many many
more
and i'm sure we will cover them but for
now i'd like to hand you back to abbott
to close the session and
as part of that i will be willing to
answer any questions
that anybody has
thank you dan we appreciate your time
today and all the valuable information
you have presented for our audience
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
before we answer questions from the
audience we would like to acknowledge
the support of the blood academy center
for hematology education
by providing the blood film images that
this webinar is based on
please visit the center at
www.bloodhyphenacademy.com
if you are interested in learning more
so let's get started on our questions
first one is
would you alter where you view the slide
on the smear if the hematocrit is
elevated or low
would you have to view an area where the
cells are further apart with a patient
with low hematocrit
that's a really good question because
with different patients
especially the difference between
pediatric and adult patients we often
see significant variation in hematocrit
we can actually
adjust the way we make the blood smear
to take that into account by altering
the angle or the speed with which the
blood smear is made using the the other
slide
to try and still obtain a portion of the
slide that we refer to as the monolayer
where the cells are still just touching
or ever so slightly overlapping
what we can find if we don't adjust the
way we make the smear
and we have to then go to the far tail
the rounded tail of the film to to see
the cells individually
that we can actually
be looking at differences in white cell
distribution because it's what
white cells are actually preferentially
distributed across a blood smear
dependent upon their size and shape as
well
so
sometimes you may have to do that if
you've got very little blood you may
have to alter where you look on the
slide
but knowing that you've had to do that
rather than not being aware of what
you're doing is the most important
aspect
trying to avoid it in the first place by
adjusting the way you make the smear
decreasing the angle of the smear
smearing slide
when the hematocrit is higher and
increasing the angle of the smearing
slide when the hematocrit is lower
actually helps avoid that problem in the
first place
great thank you
next question
is it important to grade the general
blood picture like to say for example
mild microacidic hypochromic
normocytic mildly hypochromic
once again
it's very important to follow any
locally set procedures and there are a
range of ways that blood film features
can be graded sometimes they're graded
with words as you just said in the
question such as mild moderate marked or
severe
and that can occasionally equate to
a
plus minus a plus one a plus two a plus
three
but what you have to remember is your
comments need to add value
to the results coming off the full blood
count analyzer
and
the
the degree of microcytosis the degree of
macrocytosis or the number of platelets
or
the degree of elliptocytes
can often be
assessed and information about that
obtained from the numerical results
so
it is sometimes important when you're
looking at the bigger picture to say
confirmed marked microcytosis
or confirmed moderate elliptocytosis or
mild thrombocytosis
so
for a lot of the general features
you can grade them
it's not always necessary you can just
say confirmed microcytosis present or
film reflects automated results or film
consistent with results
except when you come to one particular
feature
and that is the presence of red cell
fragments otherwise known as
schistocytes
those are one of the morphological
features where it is important to try
and grade them as number seen per high
power field because that number can be
tracked over a period of sequential days
to see if the patient is getting any
worse or if their condition is improving
there are some guidelines out there and
i would refer as many people as possible
to the icsh guidelines
or bcsh will now the bsh guidelines on
grading morphological criteria because
it is a very useful very clearly written
source of information that really does
address the question you've asked
great thank you
next question
do we observe any abnormality in red
blood cells or other blood cells in the
case of alzheimer patients
i really am not sure about that i i'm
sure there have been some studies and
there are probably papers out there that
have looked at any correlation between
that condition
and blood film features whether they be
red cells or white cells
[Music]
but
when we look at con certain conditions
it's still not clear what is the cause
of some conditions as a amyloid plaques
or prions or heavy metals in a diet
leading to certain conditions of
dementia or reduced cognition
[Music]
one might be able to say and i have no
information to back this up at this time
that if heavy metals are considered to
be
a contributing factor to certain
conditions of cognitive decline such as
dementia
then one might be able to see heavy
metal uh
heavy metal features heavy metal
poisoning features
in the blood film such as increased
basophilic stippling or increased course
basophilic stippling
i certainly think it's an area that is
interesting and could be explored
great thank you
next question
how can you tell acanthocytes apart from
burr cells or echinocytes
so
very important a very good question and
very important to be able to do this
because the clinical
connotations are distinct for these
acanthocytes
have a large number of large irregular
projections from the red cell membrane
and frequently lack their central power
and the way you say that sentence is a
way to help you remember
large
irregular projections
echinocytes on the other hand generally
are more round
and they have a higher number of small
regularly spaced
spines around the entire circumference
of the red cell if you think of what a
spiny round echinoderm one of those sea
creatures that looks like starfish
looks like
the echinocyte looks like that but the
projections are generally smaller
generally about 10 12 to 15 or more
regularly spaced around the outside of
the red cell
and the acanthocyte can have
bizarre pictures the camposites can
sometimes be described like holly leaf
appearance with a fewer number of
irregular large darker bigger
projections
thank you
and we have time for one more question
when it comes to nucleated red cells in
premature babies when should you be
worried how high does the nrbc have to
be
again
quite a tricky question because one has
to look at the bigger picture why are
you looking at the blood film in the
first place and what is the clinical
condition of the infant
that the more pre-term
a child is
the more immature their marrow is the
more immature their liver and their
lungs are and the the greater the sort
of response for the marrow to try and
compensate for those immaturities
therefore you were likely to see more
nucleated red cells
again for a pre-term infant with
coexisting
comorbidities
i i would expect to see maybe up to
about 20 nucleated red cells per hundred
white cells
nucleated red cells should actually
really be reported as times 10 to the 9
per liter as an absolute value
many places will report both
but it is a rough rule of thumb
the number of nucleated red cells will
decline as maturity conditions and you
reach the point of where it would become
a term child
in a normal term baby up to maybe five
nucleated red cells per 100 white cells
again that number will decline over the
first few days as the lungs mature and
as the marrow and the liver continues
its sort of maturation
but
you have to look at the clinical details
and in fact it's very unwise to report
any blood film for any reason without
looking at the full clinical details
because otherwise you're not
particularly clear on why you're
reporting what you're reporting
so that is one particular case where it
is important to know just how ill is the
child
and
how likely they are to
improve their clinical condition as time
goes on or it's a condition likely to
remain poor or even decline
and that's when you have to consider is
the number of nucleated red cells
appropriate
or do you have to
in fact remove any automated count and
perform the manual differential
including nucleated red cells
thank you dan do you have any final
comment for our audience
just just to say it is a very large
topic
um and to cover a lot of the features in
quite a relatively small period of time
is is difficult there is so much more to
talk about regarding the causes of
changes in red cell morphology
but i hope this has provided a
solid foundation that you can spring
forward from to
to continue learning about redstone
morphology and morphology in general and
good luck on your morphological careers
well thank you again dan for your
important and informative presentation
we would also like to thank our sponsor
abbott for underwriting today's
educational webcast please visit
abbott's hematology academy for
additional educational resources
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye